the dirt Erna chair of the energy
transitions Commission and former chair
of the Financial Services Authority and
first chair of the UK climate change
committee in a former director-general
of the CBI and also I should point out
he played a leading role in the redesign
of global banking regulation following
the 2008 financial crisis and his author
of between debt and the devil money
credit and fixing global finance let's
hear from our first speaker against the
motion Adair Turner
the debate this evening is not about
whether climate change is a potentially
catastrophic threat to humanity but
about how we effectively deal with it
George has described some of the reasons
why we have to act fast he's talked
about the Arctic sea ice the dangers of
tipping points with the methane release
the loss of corals the danger to food
supplies and I'm not going to repeat or
expand on that further because Tony and
I completely agree with that point we
are facing a potential disaster and we
have left it dangerously late to take
the action that can deal with it the
International Panel on Climate Change
says that we must limit global warming
to 1 point 5 degree centigrade above
pre-industrial levels and to do that we
will have to reduce the emissions from
industry buildings transport and
agriculture to zero by around
mid-century and I mean real zero not a
pretend zero in which we go on consuming
large amounts of fossil fuels but tell
ourselves that we bought some offsets
via some reforestation somewhere else in
the world so the objective is clear get
emissions to zero by around mid-century
the question is how to get there
one way might be to reject as georges
has suggested the very idea of
capitalist material prosperity growth
and there's certainly a role for that at
least in already developed rich
countries all of us can and I think
ideally should cut our carbon footprints
by using public transport by walking or
bicycling by reducing avoidable flights
or by reducing or eliminating red meat
consumption spending our income instead
on the many forms of capitalist product
entertainment high quality restaurant
meals things which are intensive in
design which do not require more
material goods and energy to support
them
but I think we have to be realistic
about the limits of that change our
lifestyle approach in major city centers
we can largely live without cars and our
cities will be much nicer places when we
do that but you can't do it out a car in
the small towns of rural France and the
Jala shown a yellow vest movement shows
what happens if a government ignores
that reality and in India where I have
spent the last three days discussing how
to decarbonize the Indian economy there
are 1.35 billion people currently using
about one third of the energy per capita
which we use and who want in future to
enjoy Western middle class standards of
living and that will require more energy
in their transport systems in
air-conditioning systems which for
understandable reasons are growing
rapidly and embedded in the consumer
goods they buy and I have to say to
George that if I had turned up on Monday
and told the Indians people that I was
dealing with that was the answer was
that they were not going to have the
standards of living that everybody in
this room has the conversation would
have ended at that point so well
lifestyle change has a role the main
route to radical emissions reductions
must be to use energy more efficiently
and to use only zero carbon forms of
energy and the good news is that it is
undoubtedly technically possible to get
to Net Zero by that route and we broadly
know how to do it we need to electrify
as much of the economy as possible
increasing total global electricity
supply about four or five times and all
of that electricity must be zero carbon
and that's possible because the Sun
shines down on earth each day eight
thousand times as much energy as total
human energy demand and the cost of
solar electricity of taking those
photons and turn them into electricity
has fallen over 85 percent in the
ten years so while George talked about
absolute limits to material supply
actually in relation to clean energy
once we fix the technology there is no
limit to the amount of clean energy that
we can capture and enjoy we also need to
use hydrogen in multiple applications we
can use it for instance to decarbonize
our steel production to decarbonize our
shipping and we must make that hydrogen
in a zero carbon fashion but you can do
that by electrolysis using zero carbon
electricity all of that will require
investments which if you add them up and
think about them in trillions of dollars
or trillions of pounds seem very large
but actually as a percentage of the
total global economy are relatively
small one or two percent and totally
affordable so let's be clear we can
build a zero carbon economy while
supporting growth in still poor
countries and the costs are surprisingly
small and the best way to do that is not
to reject capitalism but to regulate tax
and direct capitalist activity while
still using private enterprise
incentives and market competition to
help get there at least cost and what
that means is that we need to have
strong policies to force capitalism to
do what we want it to do while leaving
it to decide the details of how we get
there we could and we should ban all
sales of internal combustion engines
from let us say 2030 but we should lend
leave it to competing capitalist firms
driven by the profit motive to work out
how to build electric vehicles in the
most efficient fashion and I believe
that we should ban all plastic
incineration all plastic exports and all
plastics sent to landfill by at the very
latest 2025 and impose a carbon price on
fossil fuel inputs into new plastics
production but we should then leave it
to private enterprise to determine the
precise mix of mechanical or chemical
recycling technologies which we know
exist and which could enable us to
continue using plastics in many
applications but in a zero carbon
fashion
now right-wing ideologues will of course
argue that if you regulate and tax
capitalism in this fashion it's no
longer capitalism at all that the only
capitalism possible is the ultra
free-market totally unregulated
capitalism beloved by people like Donald
Trump but that is nonsense because
capitalism can come in many different
forms and we can choose the form we want
capitalism and here I agree with George
means essentially a system in which most
but not all not necessarily all of the
means of production distribution
exchange are owned by private enterprise
competing in markets to make profit and
capitalism can flourish and deliver
benefits for Humanity even if and indeed
precisely because it is tightly
regulated and appropriately taxed indeed
capitalism was most successful in
delivering prosperity to the many not
just the few when in the nineteen
fifties and sixties it was combined with
very tight regulation of the financial
sector with a significant role for
state-owned enterprises in some specific
sectors of the economy and with top
marginal tax rates far above current
levels but nobody doubted that Germany
Britain and America in the 1950s and 60s
were capitalist economies delivering
both more rapid growth and far better
environmental results than the non
capitalist economies of Russia or
Eastern Europe three weeks ago
George presented a fascinating TV
documentary called apocalypse cow in it
he argued that to stop climate collapse
we must radically reduce the role of
land intensive agriculture and I agreed
almost entirely with his arguments like
George I think we are probably on the
cusp of the technological revolution
which will enable us to continue if we
want to enjoy the taste of red meat but
produced in a synthetic fashion which
does not involve destructive
deforestation nor terrible lives for
sentient beings and to illustrate that
exciting technological potential George
flew and he admitted this was breaking
his normal rules he flew to Finland
and to visit a company called solar
foods which is developing synthetic ways
of producing carbohydrates which we can
then either consume directly or use as
feedstock for synthetic meats so what
type of company is solar foods well it's
a private capitalist company raising
money from private investors who will
expect a good return on their risky
investment and while solar Foods
managers undoubtedly want to do good for
the world they and their investors may
well also be motivated by the fact that
if they succeed they will make good
money I think we must embrace the
innovative potential of capitalism even
while constraining it taxing it
regulating it and pointing it in the
right direction and if instead we try to
abolish capitalism I fear we will not
stop climate catastrophe but make it
more likely
[Applause]